MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we
talk about nuclear fission.
Already seen the process
when we discussed
empirical mass formula.
Nuclear fission occurs
in very heavy nuclei,
as you can see in this plot
here, fission processes,
and this part of the spectrum.
But what happens, and what
can happen spontaneously,
is that the parent nuclei
just simply breaks up
into daughter nuclei and maybe
some additional neutrons.
One example is the
decay of uranium 238.
One can also induce fission.
Here, is a plot of the nuclear
potential with the Coulomb
[? law ?] here.
And for example, you have
this nuclei which sits here--
and this could be uranium 238--
and you are able to bring
it above this activation
and energy.
Again, this can, in some nuclei,
occur spontaneously, in others,
it's being induced.
And then you just
break up the two,
break up the nuclei into
two daughter particles.
So if you, for example,
start with a neutron
and you just bring
it close-- let's
say you bring a neutron
close to uranium 235.
This forms uranium 236.
And the fact that the neutron
is being absorbed excites,
then, this zero-kinetic
energy neutron
excite the daughter
compound nucleus.
There's an excitation
[INAUDIBLE] in this case,
of 6.5 MeV.
And because of that, it then
quickly undergoes fission.
So we basically add its thermal,
or zero-kinetic energy neutron,
and when it's being
absorbed it immediately
causes the fission process.
The fission fragments then
carry away some energy--
in this example, here,
it's about 180 MeV--
and additional prompt neutrons.
And so those additional
prompt neutrons,
depending on the
specific decay process,
the number can be varying
between zero and six,
and for uranium 235, the
average number is 2.5.
And then the
fragments, they might
undergo additional decay
process, maybe better decays,
alpha decays.
And when they do
that, they can also
release additional neutrons.
So interesting, now, is
to see whether or not
there can be a self-sustained
reaction, a chain reaction.
And whether or not this
occurs depends on the number
of neutrons being emitted.
So if the number of
neutrons produced
in the n plus first stage
of the fission process
is greater than the number of
neutrons produced in the nth
stage of the
process, the process
is either critical
or super critical,
which means that it is able
to, because it produces more
neutrons and it
needs to continue
to have a fission process,
it will add or create
a chain reaction.
If the number is less than
1, the process will die out.
And this is exactly what's used
in nuclear fission reactors.
There's several types
of reactors available.
The example I want
to discuss here
very briefly is the one
of a thermal reactor which
uses uranium as fuel
and low-energy neutrons
to establish the chain
reaction, as we just discussed.
And so this is a sketch here.
And the sketch has three
different elements.
The first one is a fuel element.
The fuel element can be
naturally-occurring uranium.
And then, we have a
moderator material.
And the purpose of
the moderator material
is to slow the neutrons down.
So if you really start from
naturally-occurring uranium,
you might have to find
some sort of material which
allows you to efficiently
slow down the neutrons
when they're being emitted
in the fusion process.
And this could be,
so-called, heavy water,
where the hydrogen in
water is replaced in part
that leaves this deuterium.
But there's other
examples for this as well.
And then, you have those very
important retractable rods.
They are materials which
have a large cross-section
to capture neutrons.
And so what you can do with
them by mechanically adding them
or removing them from
this environment,
is you can remove
additional neutrons.
So what you're trying to do
is control this number k here,
control whether or not there's
enough neutrons available
in order to sustain
the chain reaction.
And then, the excess energy
is converted in heat.
You can, for example, heat
up water and then just
have a turbine run in
order to produce energy.